[Musique]
o o
et maintenant retrouvons une nouvelle
histoire de papy grenier
les enfants voilà comme chaque mois hors
champ et avec entrevoir de chipmunks
habib attitude raconte une histoire à
une histoire
tout a commencé il ya 4,56 milliards
d'années quand la terre n'était qu'une
boule de feu gigantesque aucun hôpital
est bon d'accord ce que je vous ai
rencontré la fois où j'étais agent
secret c'est en 1997
[Musique]
ça va pourquoi tout le monde réagit
comme ça
oh la la bon j'étais là pour lutter
contre les communistes je vais mettre un
terme à votre idéologie barbare de
répartition équitable des richesses
je me souvienne tout avait commencé sur
un barrage qui était gardé par les pires
soldats russes du monde n'était pas très
mal nous devrons connaître
[Musique]
et [ __ ] là je suis presque sûr qu'il
ya quelqu'un à t'emmerde brugeois ses
chaussures voiture mais quand même
c'était des vrais soldats on leur avait
appris à ignorer la douleur tant qu'il
ne voyait pas l'ennemi ils restent
fidèles à leur poste sur moi c'est ok ya
du monde quand ils voyaient ils
devenaient des vraies machines à tuer je
me souviens de leur mode opératoire
c'était toujours la même chose d'abord
il te braquet après il arrêtait ensuite
il faisait un pas de côté en fut titre
bras qui se mettait à genoux il faisait
une roulade
je m'étonne qu'ils étaient faciles à
tuer je vous que deux fois je me
demandais si l'on rajoute c'est pas un
peu exprès bon c'est à dire les gars
c'est que j'ai un pote à moi en fait
qu'il ya un gros problème
il se prend pour un agent secret donc
soyez sympa avec lui est rentré dans son
délire 1 mais surtout surtout essayer de
molière de façon subtile et naturel ok
bon après des fois ça leur arrivait
quand même de toucher ça tu prends une
balle tu as fais pas ça bon ah oui tu as
raison mais bon je suis un pansement
dans leur mort moi j'adore j'étais un
agent secret un j'avais une montre qui
donnait pas leur et surtout j'avais
plein d'armes j'avais mon pépé c'est
silencieux j'avais des ak-47 j'avais des
fusils de sniper j'avais dts car rien ne
vaut un des scop pour tirer un bon coup
un nom de petit con ma mission c'était
de retrouver le goldeneye je dois avouer
quand même que j'étais pas un très bon
agent secret je passais tout mon temps à
dessiner des [ __ ] sur les murs avec les
impacts de balle je sautais des barrages
sans élastique et j'explose est
systématiquement tout ce que je voyais
des caves et une télé ou un écran je me
sentais obligé 2-2 fut pour le faire
exploser santé d'ailleurs que des fois
ça agace et les gens autour de moi
j'aime ce qui est délicat
[Musique]
d'ailleurs quand j'y repense c'était
bizarre que même tout exposer les
chaises les meubles les lampes de bureau
même les maquettes de voitures en
plastique explosé quand on tirait dessus
à croire que michael bay s'était mis à
bosser chez ricard enfin bref pour cette
mission j'étais accompagné de nathalie à
une scientifique rousse aveugle et à
forte tendance suicidaire un qu'elles
connaissent je me souviens de ces
moments où on se retrouvait tous les
deux dans l'ascenseur j'ai toujours aimé
les femmes un peu froide avec moi elle
restait toujours de marbre même quand je
danse et devant elle mais je savais que
ça lui faisait de l'effet on été collés
l'un à l'autre cette ambiance tellement
romantique est tellement intimiste que
j'ai sorti mon arme et que je lui ai
tiré dans la chine de croiser le soldat
russe est totalement idiot qui voit le
mieux je m'amuse impute au monde au fait
j'en ai vécu des aventures âge
souviens quand j'ai été fait prisonnier
avec natalia et que j'ai réussi à
m'échapper devant le garde grâce à ma
montre magnétique
ah là là c'était pour fast il
[Musique]
mais bon des fois on croisait d'autres
agents ils venus des quatre coins du
monde des fois c'était un peu bizarre il
y avait des soldats russes des nains
avec d autres formes d metchel ou en
chemise hawaïenne
on connaissait pas bien la procédure
alors on agissait à l'instinct c'est
vrai j'ai toujours trouvé ça bizarre moi
d'allemagne je me souviens de dd la
science il aimait bien posé plein milan
foot est sûre et gilet pare-balles il en
mettait dans les angles déportés et
surtout valu ne pas aller aux toilettes
a prévu parce qu'il en coûtait partout
des mines d'accord il y avait aussi
riton le passe-muraille c'était la
victime c'était le mec qui se cachait
tout le temps à lui consacrer phénomène
ce rite ont il aimait bien se cacher et
cacher les trucs des autres y y
poussaient les gilets pare balles dans
les murs il était un peu coquin mais bon
tu es encore trop jeune pour connaître
les armes toi tu devras attendre d'être
au collège public pour ça la violence
entre amis ça s'explique pas bhl il faut
la vivre la violence
papy tu gagnes est toujours au pas
toujours mais bon on n'oublie pas
l'important c'est pas de gagner
l'important c'est du milieu de son
adversaire mais papy c'est pas une
histoire c'est un jeu vidéo
[Musique]
oh bien sûr mais ce sera pour la
prochaine fois
[Musique]
hu